finalmente ragazzi siamo qui con le
televendite migliorando era ora perché
quando ci vende tutto quello che volete
vi vende tutto la regia non ha anche
acceso le luci fantastico grazie grazie
a tutti
giorgio inquadra mi guarda inquadra
tutto non mi fai vedere alla gente cosa
c'è in basso giorgio guarda c'è un
tapiola stringimi che devo parlare i
ragazzi stringi vuol dire che deve venir
vicino vicino dove li avete assunti
questi qua alla bocciofila devi
stringere qua perfetto o cosi cosi io
posso parlare alla gente spiegare che
cosa sta succedendo oggi iniziano le
televendite divorando io sono sandro
laurent do io vivendo degli oggetti che
voi dovete assolutamente avere in casa
oggetti che servono per vivere per
essere più felici per andare dai vostri
amici di riguarda ios e colorando e o
questo oggetto che tutti gli altri non
hanno
io vi dico questo è il mio set questa è
la mia arte questo è mario schifano tra
l'altro voi che non sapete le cose che
vi dovete informare i ragazzi
informatevi questo è uno schifano non ho
bisogno di un ambiente confidente per
venderli una cosa perché questa cosa è
talmente bella che si vende da sola io
non potrei dire neanche niente si vende
da sola che cos'è questo questo è
l'oggetto che vivendo oggi
ed è un oggetto incredibile si chiama 0
con il link in descrizione poi potrete
acquistare questo fantastico oggetto
solo la qualità ragazzi io sono su un
tapis o una perché è talmente forte come
oggetto questo che me lo posso vendere
anche giorgio deve inquadrare me e
giorgio deve inquadrare me sono io
l'anima di tutta questa cosa devi
guardare messo noi non parlo con la
gente ma la gente non mi non mi vede
vedermi
io sto parlando con voi voi siete qua
questo è l'oggetto avete mai provato ad
utilizzare lo smartphone sotto il sole
signor andò ci ho provato però sotto il
sole ci sono dei problemi non vedo mai
lo schermo a era qui che vi volevo poi
non vedete mai lo schermo perché il sole
è più grande nemico di tutti noi global
warming greta tombeur un casino e noi
come risolviamo questo problema come ve
lo risolve laurent
ve lo risolve così con la pinza con lo
smartphone
et voilà il sole non è più un ostacolo
perché zero è in grado di coprirmi dal
sole e anche da un sacco di intemperie
quale la pioggia se vostro nonno vi
racconta della guerra e nel mentre voi
volete giocare a minecraft disputati a
sul telefono tra che ombrellino 6 ad un
primo appuntamento comincia a piovere
lei si sta bagnando il cellulare 0 neve
bagnarsi solo lei
stai mangiando una minestra cava e paura
di sporcare il cellulare 0
il nonno sputacchia dappertutto mentre
racconta come sopravvissuto alla guerra
0 in descrizione lo trovate subito
perché poi esauriscono i primi che
compreranno questo oggetto potranno
averlo tutto per loro ragazzi ci sono
solo scorte limitate chiamate fatevi
sentire
passatemi la chiamata ragazzi se ce
l'avete passatemela giorno inquadra per
cortesia
grazie pronto pronto
la sento pronto sono signor giorgio
armani in persona il signor armani
orlando che il suo brillino è davvero
stiloso mio dio sono un po emozionato
non mi aspettavo di parlare con il
signor armani alla prima chiamata vedi
giorgio un giorno importante
finalmente si inquadra me e giorgio che
il signor armani non mi vede signor
armani io sono un fan
oggi lei ha chiamato per un oggetto
veramente importante quanti negozi a
milano 20 30 quanti dipendenti aventi a
negozio
abbiamo un totale di un migliaio di
dipendenti e ne compri uno per
dipendente ma lo sai che figura fa
quando uno entra ad armani e vede uno
con un ombrellino così ma che non compra
tutto il negozio signor armani ma suvvia
ma signore e signori signore e signori
ancora non vi ho detto
la caratteristica principale
nell'oggetto perché innanzitutto lo
potete mettere ovunque guardatelo tirato
fuori
manco fossi jack nobile perché è un
oggetto del genere ma quanto può costare
laurent dopo costare tantissimo è un
oggetto innovativo
quindi possiamo venderlo mai a 150 ma
oggi non lo vendiamo a 150 possiamo
venderlo a 100 ma neanche 100 ragazzi
oggi oggi ve lo dico
ve lo dico signori
799 questo lo vendiamo a sette no e
regalato e vostro a 799 incredibile
giorno non possiamo fare questa cosa non
possiamo farlo questa casa vostra per
799 una gioia incredibile
fate questa offerta perché non ve ne
pentirete mai 799 è impossibile ragazzi
prendetelo perché un'offerta del genere
si stanno puntando pistole qua lo
rendono puoi farlo ma io lo faccio
pinzate rosso linking descrizione
pinzate lo perché la pizza è molto
importante la smettiamo ad inquadrare
schifano giorgio ed all'inizio del video
che inquadri schifano e basta
schifano lo vendiamo in un altro
episodio voi dovete schiacciare linking
descrizione imperdibile ci sono solo
pochi pezzi solo chi lo fa adesso riesce
a prenderlo file finalmente giorgio
fatto anche l'inquadratura giusta è che
la volete perdere e non la perdete
questa inquadratura non perdete
l'oggetto della vostra vita linking
descrizione schiacciatelo tutti chiamate
la nonna chiamate vostra mamma
tutti devono schiacciare la descrizione
il sole è diventato un problema
risolvete lo con zero linking
descrizione ragazzi e comunque laurent
dovi vende sempre cose
incredibilmente utili quindi tranquilli
non vi sto prendendo in giro
l'oggetto è meraviglioso spegnete tutto
linking descrizione e via così devi
chiudere giorgio non sai fare